let's go to northern california where
firefighters are battling
two massive wildfires as wind gusts fan
the flames at least six people have died
already
and our jonathan vigliotti is near the
flames in healsburg
good morning to you most of these fires
have moved into steep terrain which is
complicating efforts this morning
to contain them as you mentioned more
than a million acres have burned in just
over one week and to give you some
context here
that's more than three times the typical
wildfire season
and resources are stretched in
this is what california firefighters are
up against
fast moving flames raging out of control
the fires are so relentless they wiped
out trees in california's oldest
state park home to famous redwoods some
2500 years old
even highly trained crews have been
caught off guard
two firefighters had to be lifted to
safety after flames
trapped them in heavy brush guys are
okay man
over the weekend firefighters used a
break in the weather to try to gain
ground
but forecast calling for 65 mile per
hour winds
and dry lightning threatened to spark
new fires
and now another round of dry lightning
and the forecast
when you hear that what goes on in your
mind be
extra ready to go i mean stay up all
night
brian washington has been with cal fire
the state's main firefighting agency
for more than 20 years however long it
takes we're going to be out here
and do what we got to do to make
everybody safe put the fires out
so everybody can go home and just get
back to
normal but this is kind of the new norm
president trump has declared the fires a
major disaster freeing up federal aid
some 200 members of the national guard
have been activated
and firefighters from 10 states have
been sent in
boy thank you jonathan the video and the
situation terrifying there there is no
good scenario thank you